No. I was playing Mario kart with someone and they couldn't drift on Mario kart.
And I thought, this is a very basic mechanic. This is not that hard time.
And I was like, you should just try it. Like without the baby modem, like,
as I feel like the baby mode, just all you're then doing is holding a right,
like without bees, because the fun part about Mario kart right. Is drifting.
Right. And nailing drifts, you know, and you know, playing the game.
I like drifting and Mario kart. Okay. I'm going to say that like 90th time. Um,
so.
I love drifting. And you said that as if it's an unpopular opinion.
I was playing with someone the other day. Right. And I was like, I was like,
they couldn't be.
I'm glad you
[inaudible].
Ladies that's so they couldn't beat me in Mario kart. Right. And I'm like, yeah.
It's because you're not drifting.
You're never going to beat me if you're not drifting. And they were like, Oh,
okay. I guess I'll try. And they tried it once. Right. They try to,
they try without Bape murder and they kept falling off the edge.
And they were like, no, I don't like Myra now it's not fun. I'm like,
what did you expect? You were just going to be amazing right away. No,
you got to put some effort in, start living out a drift. You dumb. Try it.
[Inaudible] fact that you've gotten that competitive over the barrier car just
shows how much like your mentor just shows all your mentality.
Drives me insane when people try something like that. Right.
That is not that mad. Okay. We're not talking about, I'm not like,
just get good at StarCraft, bro. I'm not asking that I'm like,
press one button on Mario kart. When you come to the corner,
that's all I'm asking. Right.
That's what I'm trying to explain to people who like throw a fit and like,
I don't wanna play it anymore. It's not fun.
Now I failed this one mechanic and I don't care to learn it.
Like that drives me insane.
I can imagine the dad, you're going to be like, son,
you can't drift America. You're you're disappointed. [inaudible].
I do not have like, people will be like, wow, Kaunas that guy with? Like,
cause to me fighting game combos are absurd.
Like the amount of combos and inputs you have to put in, it's just too much.
Like there was just such a steep learning curve. Right.
There'll be a fighting game if you'd be up in arms and be like, okay,
I like that. That's the drifting.
And Mario kart is such a low barrier of entry in terms of intense mechanics.
But like, you know, it is, is it really, do you think it is?
I know some people who just, no matter what game it is, some people just don't,
their brains just don't operate. Right. When it comes to like games,
even a simple mechanical, like drifting. They're just like.
I think to me, it's like, if they had never wanted a drift, it's fine,
but they wanted a drift and one of the learn, right.
And then it was difficult and they gave up immediately.
And that that's what annoyed me is that they immediately gave up.
Well, I mean, not, this is how did you get anything done,
but isn't that the equivalent of you playing Tekken and being like,
I want to do this combo and you try. And you're like, I don't like it.
I would try the combo and I'd be at it. I get my clowned on that.
I realize I'm just not getting better at this game.
Right? No, not the first.
I would try multiple sessions to get good at it. It's just,
it's just the same thing with, uh, with a different difficulty.
You know what I mean? It's just like,
it's just a different life versus I have three lives.
Why? I said I prefaced right in the start. I'm like,
it's not like I'm asking you to get good at StarCraft or anything intense.
I'm not asking you to learn intense mechanics pacing.
It is Mario kart drift explain.
Yeah. But you have to understand people for some people that is intense.
I refuse to believe that.
So you're telling your grandma can figure out Marriott car straight away.
If you're my age, Mario kart drifting should not be an intense mechanic. I, I,
I think it's like early onset dementia. If that is a problem for you, honestly.
There's some big claims.
I would expect my grandma to even know how to get like,
just click the menu on the Nintendo switch. Right.
I'm not expecting her to do that. Right. Very extremely basic mechanics. Right.
Like, okay. But this is the, okay. Again, this is not a problem with that.
They can't do it. This is, they gave up right away.
The first failure of the first track that like I'm done.
Well, maybe because they don't want a challenging experience in a video game.
Maybe they just want to play for like that. You like the Navy seals that.
I despised though. Those people [inaudible] No,
I would never expect someone to be good at any video game.
Are you trying to say that your play Mario kart for fun? No. No, no.
It's all about the challenge. It's about the huddle. Okay. How about you?
I would never claim to be,
I want to be good at fighting games and then I'll try and give up, right?
If I want to actually learn something I'm going to, I'm going to do it.
I'm going to throw a hissy fit and give up what, I'm not good at it.
That's just how you operate.
So you have to realize not everyone is an Epic game ago.
Some people just don't see games that way. And you just have to accept that.
I just think it was annoying. No, I get it. I get like,
that's annoying to me as well, but I'm not going to get like off at them.
I'm just like, well, that's just, that's just how you play.
That just means probably you just ain't in the game for them.
They just don't like playing games like that.
Nearly off the top of my head.
I can't think of an easier mechanic to learn than the Mario kart drift. Can you
[inaudible] mechanic go right down.
Ugly. I'm celebrating and Mario. No, it's automatic now, Jerry.
Yeah. There's an option. There's an option for what?
It's all automatic by default. So you don't even have to do that.
Turning in Mario cart, baby mode. It's automatic.
What I'm saying there is literally the game plan. That's what I'm saying.
There's a reason why they added those mechanics because for some people,
because they want this it's too much. That's what I'm saying.
They just want the monkey brain near an activation
card might be a baby game. But for some people it's the equivalent of playing.
No, I said it was a PB game. I'm just saying right.
What happened to us is that they, they want no,
they were complaining that I was winning. Right.
You'll never going to win if you don't drift. Right.
So my problem was that the complaint that I'm winning,
I told them how I was winning. I explained to them, this is how you can do it.
And how easy of a mechanic it is to learn.
Like you can learn it in one sitting very comfortably.
I think like most people would, if they actually just tried.
So they just gave up.
Just, just start winning son, just winning,
winning son. Why are you winning? Why aren't you winning?
It would never get to that point. My son be in discerned before.
I would be like, why haven't you won already? So that's why I don't know.
My son was winning. Kind of doesn't ask, are you winning?
You're winning riser.
Hi, am I the for thinking? That's like, just like, I don't know.
You should maybe just put like, I don't know.
Complaining about competitive Mario kart.
I complain about the part that they gave up immediately and were like,
I can't do it. I hate when people do that. Like I just.
I hate it too, but I'm not like like losing my. I don't give a about it.
It's supposed to give a marriage. If they don't want to win in Mario,
that's America. I don't give a. I can to give a. If someone gives up in America,
guys.
I see fit. And I'm like, that's your problem, man. Stop giving up on in life.
This is why you get nothing done.
The Navy seals,
you never excelled at anything sound because you gave up the first time.
If you'll get it,
if you're getting a pissy over someone like losing and Mariko or something and
throwing it in America, something more intensive in life.
Out of context, I'm thinking they were getting off.
And then it kind of me off that they were getting off about it.
Cause they didn't put any effort in well.
Yeah, but you tried to got me like with a gotcha moment.
On fighting games and it's completely not related at all.
You.
Gave me an entirely different situation. No, no, no, no.
We're saying what we're saying is that you got off at someone having a hearsay
thing. I wouldn't even bother getting off at someone having a
[inaudible] to me, I was like, what's wrong? Basic.
Basically the like them giving up or not being able to learn drift in America is
exactly the same situation.
As you not being able to learn the difficulty curve in the fighting game.
It's completely different thing. Right? If that was my own choosing. Right.
And I went through that or like someone pushed me on it. They were like,
you should start letting combos. Right.
I can totally understand if I was pushing it on them,
but they wouldn't want to do it. I wouldn't want be good at it because I mean,
that's, I'm putting on them. They never wanted to do it in the first place.
But if we're pushing them to drift, no, I never said that he did no. They said,
how was I winning? I said drifting. And they were like, Oh, I want to do that.
I literally said that. So putting words in my mouth, Jerry you.
What I'm saying is like, if I chose, if I was pushed into doing it,
totally understand why you would then give up basically just, Hey,
you just say people who give up. I hate people who give up right away.
I hate it, dude.
What's what's the right amount before someone gives up when it becomes
acceptable. Yeah.
I mean, you can tell if you're like good at something,
when someone just isn't getting the hang of it and they aren't going to get a
hang of it. You know what I mean?
Like if you haven't been doing scent for a long time,
you can just tell they're struggling. Right. Right. But like most people,
like a lot of those people, there's a fair amount.
People out there who are perfectly capable of doing something.
We just give up immediately because they failed the first time. Yeah.
Probably where you guys with ranked games. I imagine. I mean,
I don't give up immediately. I just get bored.
I don't even, I don't even start.
Because I know I'm going to hate it because you,
you have a hissy fit when you lose a games. Yeah.
I don't want to have a hissy fit.
When I'm losing a game. Why that's not,
why you get a hissy fit when you lose a game.
Because when does it ever feel that there's someone naming ultimate me a moment
where I'm like, Oh man, I lost like, no one says that.
I don't give a when I lose it again. I'm like, all right, well, fair enough.
I got, I got out, played, you know, man, what is it? What is that?
Does that feel good to you?
Sometimes if I know where like I could have got wrong with you? No,
I think I hear it. I think it is like, it's a healthier mindset to be of.
I don't mind losing so I can improve.
That's that is the complete opposite experience. My bro, my friend,
the league experiences. me. I lost. Was it my fault?
Or was it my teammate's fault? I have literally no fun.
No, I did ask no and league when it was completely my fault. I mean,
there are some games, you know, it is horrible.
There is some games when you it's like the 50 50 game and then your teammate is
just,
Cortel one V five while like you're all doing Baron or something and then you
just lose the game. Thanks for that. And it's that, that feels horrible.
That feels awful.
It feel great. But then I, you know, you can leave that game, be like, right.
I could have set that up better. I could have,
could have done things better that make that w more secured. Right?
I don't look at games that deep, man. I just do it to escape.
I don't look at it deep. What happens is that I enjoy games.
And then I look into now, when we're talking about it, I'm thinking, okay,
why do I enjoy the games that way? And that's why I'm talking about it now.
I'm not just sitting there my window sill. Like,
why do I enjoy suffering league? I don't know.
Is the question that we're posing. Why do you enjoy [inaudible].
Play the game.
[Inaudible].
I've played a ranked game of league, like two months, man, three months.
I went to Liza anonymous and I just, I just said it, man. I was like, yeah,
I'm for leak-free congratulations, everybody claps.
I've played a basically I enjoy league the most when I don't care about winning
or losing. Like that's, that's literally,
that's literally my enjoyment of those types of competitive games.
And I think Joe is just a little game, a, little, little crybaby boy. Uh,
and that's what we're going to end it today. I'm sorry. I enjoy winning a game.
I'm sorry. I just enjoy going to,
so be one of those old people like these kids these days,
they don't know how to lose, let alone how to lose it all.
How do they expect to win at life? If they can't even video games?
How can you expect to win at lifeguard when you can't even take a loss in smash
bros? Joey, I don't know, man. I'm winning so far. It's funny.
Wait until that loss comes along, Joey,
you'll be able to suffer as a human being. You've been to work. Oh no.
I apologize that I'm giving off a very normal human experience.
People take enough ELLs in life.
Life throws enough people that some people would just want an escape from that.
You know what I mean? Some people want some
escape to a secure daddy's literally disagree.